from this i don't even know if i want to
do this anymore like this is
messed up stuff to this i
cannot believe there's a hundred million
supporters following me right now
charlie demilio made a quick comeback
over the weekend hitting 100
million followers on tick tock that is
insane
oh my goodness joe can't like grasp that
this is real i still feel like it's a
dream
kind of waiting to wake up the 16 year
old is the first ever tick tock star to
reach the huge milestone
those numbers can't even register in my
head that's so crazy
but charlie came close to not hitting
the record-breaking moment
after she and her sister dixie received
backlash
over a new family youtube video titled
dinner with the demilios
what is this oh my god
it's a mushroom no it's not that's a
snail
oh snail
it's the kind of coal it's classic
and it's actually uh uh omen of good
luck and fortune
i just touched its liver oh my god
liver there's a it's
do we have any dino yeah
fans weren't too happy about the way
they treated their personal chef
and charlie appearing to complain about
her following
didn't help either oh i wish i wish i
had like more time
because imagine if i hit a hundred mil a
year after hitting a mill
was the 95 not enough for you well i was
just like saying like
even numbers well the influencer
lost 1 million followers and broke down
on
insta live they don't tell people to
kill themselves
at the end of the day i'm still a person
no matter how many followers i have
you can hate on me for whatever i've
done but the fact that all of this is
happening because i
a misunderstanding like i just feel like
that's not okay
and if this is the community that i'm in
in the community that i put myself
in i don't know if i want to do that
anymore but
it now looks like things have taken a
turn for the social media star
like if you really think about
everything that's happened like
like what that's it's just kind of crazy
charlie's friends showed their support
like james charles who tweeted
congratulations charlie dimiglio i am so
incredibly proud of you
and your growth and fellow tick talker
addison ray wrote
a hundred million how insane i can't
believe i met you a year ago
time flies when you're having fun i love
you it makes it so worth it because no
matter what anyone says i do what i do
for all these people that say
i inspire them